[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
you
[Applause]
remember when we saw him standing over a
cliff roll out a dream in my whole
carnival of my see you in my every new
knew just what I was there for Dana
heard me saying a prayer for my in
Louisville someone I really could care
for never came out you and then there
suddenly appeared before me
oh the only one my hey I heard somebody
whispering boy had to be you without a
dream in my home
Oh
[Applause]
you
sometimes I wonder why I spend the
lonely nights dreaming the song the
melody haunts my reverie and I am once
again with you when I love
and is an inspiration
but that was long ago now my consolation
is in the Stardust the soul being side a
garden when stars are bruh
you are a nightingale a paradise where
though I dream in May and my heart it
will
Stardust Moody the memory of Love's
refrain
[Applause]
welcome back baby
say woman please don't go cause the way
that I love you you will never know no
unless you come back to me baby
well then let's just talk it over just
one more time
just one more time baby well I will
admit that I was wrong oh yes I was
wrong deep in my heart I feel as though
you've been gone too long so please come
back to me baby
Wheelan just the two of us let's sit
down and talk about good times we have
in each other just one more time
Billy Haleh like a mop and Jack
build up people I'd walk up on a
mountain and I would call my baby back
not sit on her phone he's come home with
me baby
girl let me see how nice I can be to you
and if we can enjoy each other at least
one more time
at least one more time
because one of these days girl
well it might not be long oh yes here
you just might want to find me down
girl and I will be gone so right now
come back
maybe let's talk it over
happy
you
I want little sugar in my
I wanna lose sweetness down in my soul
I could stand some
oh so bad I feel so funny
you feel so say a wallenstein on my
clothes maybe I can fix things up so
we'll go
[Laughter]
what's the matter daddy come on
save my soul I need some shove in my eye
I want some sugar
Oh
you've been acting different I've been
to sue me I want some sugar in my eye
some steam on my clothes maybe I can fix
things up so they'll go
what's manner that is
come on save my soul I want some up
in my bow I ain't foolin
I want some sugar
in my bow
you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
here's one that really needs no
introduction so weighing I'll give it
now you wanna talk about you may start
something you know to keep a body out to
be you smart let your feet get to bump
in turn the music on a rap the walls a
little when the neighbors are
complaining and remaining you know the
time to dampen
people you know when their path their
feet breathing get them alive in the Reg
groove attack with them that's maybe got
ones electrical broad daylight rash the
gate with some Francis's hope the party
never ends
what a party oh the party oh sorry I
thought of creepin and take a peep in
but when I saw the same yeah
what a party's what a hearty I never saw
so many people really jump in especially
after one o'clock
I mean am juggling I'm not holding any
meetings anymore when you eat Islam from
Spain I'm on the clock
Oh
get ready let's jump stead of drunken
got me don't be so busy our good days
early routing basis Bhutan this fall and
got me Carla but above the jumping
started shortly after one o'clock people
it and tables whenever
when the door was open I'll keep
roadhouse get moving out so keep
grooving I wanna clock jump jump jump
jump jump jump on jump I run jump jump
jump jump jump and his mom jumping on
jumper
we're gonna do the one
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
you
ah
[Applause]
Oh
you
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president I hereby declare this
hooding ceremony for the candidates for
the degree of Doctor of Philosophy to be
in session
good afternoon no no this is a
celebration we're gonna try this again
good afternoon
much better my name is Farnum Johanna
and I'm the provost and chief academic
officer here at Carnegie Mellon
University welcome to the celebration of
one of academia's
most venerable traditions a time when
the Carnegie Mellon community comes
together to celebrate the achievements
of our candidates for the degree of
Doctor of Philosophy and Doctor of Arts
and to award these individuals their
doctoral hoods
[Music]
as a research institution one of the
core missions of Carnegie Mellon
University is to develop talented new
scholars who can demonstrate deep
mastery of a body of knowledge
originality of thought an openness to
collaborative inquiry as doctoral
graduates you're the embodiment of that
purpose and today is the culmination of
several years of intense scholarly
pursuits and deep immersion in your
discipline today when you truly become
scholars but you've done it you're done
I can almost feel the sense of relief
emanating from all of you candidates
take my advice take a deep breath and
enjoy the ceremony it might be a bit
long but each name will we will call
represents a fellow CMU colleague who
has reached the pinnacle of their
studies each with a unique journey that
has led to this moment so enjoy
yourselves and bask in your success and
the success of your peers there is no
doubt that you have earned it as we
recognize your hard work and
achievements this afternoon I am
grateful to our faculty members who have
advised and supported you throughout
your studies faculty thank you for
joining us to celebrate this year's
class of doctoral students
you beat me to it but I'm going to make
you do it again please join me in
thanking our faculty for dedication and
their support much better I would also
like to congratulate and thank the many
people tonight who have made the road
easier for these dedicated women and men
as they focus so intensely under
scholarship spouses partners parents
children's friends this day is also
yours please join me in expressing our
thanks to your families and your friends
[Applause]
throughout your doctoral studies you
have made your mark on the intellectual
landscape of this campus and you will
now make your place among our steamed
community of scholars through your
achievements to come you will bring
honor and prestige to Carnegie Mellon
and enhanced opportunities of the
graduate students who will follow you in
many cases you will change the lives of
people around the world for the better
or make significant impact on a body of
knowledge I wish you a prosperous future
and I offer my sincere congratulations
on your achievements it is now my
pleasure to introduce Carnegie Mellon's
ninth resident dr. subra Suresh who will
introduce this afternoon's keynote
speaker dr. Suresh
[Applause]
Thank You forum good afternoon everyone
the doctor'll celebrations doctor'll
hooting celebrations are very special
because the bond that forms between a
thesis advisor and a graduate student
lasts a lifetime because often times
they overlap intellectual domains even
if the two of them move into very
different fields over a period of time
so this is a very special bond so I
would like to start by congratulating
all the PhD graduates today and their
thesis advisors the faculty for creating
this bond at Carnegie Mellon University
and I'm sure this bond will be further
strengthened and nurtured in the years
to come so congratulations to the
graduates and to the faculty
then we also add my congratulations to
the family and friends who have stood
with you through your journey as you
seek to gain a PhD degree whether it's
three years four years five years or six
plus years and hopefully on the shorter
side it is now my pleasure to introduce
our distinguished speaker a great
neighbor and friend to Carnegie Mellon
dr. Arthur s Levine as senior vice
chancellor for the Health Sciences and
the John and Gertrude Peters and Dean of
the School of Medicine at the University
of Pittsburgh
dr. Levine works closely with the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
and one of the largest academic medical
centers in the nation under his
direction the Medical School ranked
among the top 10 in funding from the
National Institutes of Health and it's
faculty now ranked fifth in NIH research
funding as you know CMU doesn't have a
medical school and the bond that forms
between our various schools and colleges
at Carnegie Mellon and the medical
school at the University of Pittsburgh
and UPMC hospitals is very special for
many of the intellectual disciplines
where our faculty excel during dr.
Levine's tenure Pitt has launched a
number of multidisciplinary research
centers and Institute's including its
Brain Institute drug discovery Institute
Center for vaccine research and
Institute for personalized medicine in
2006 the university was one of 12
American institutions awarded the first
clinical and translational science
awards by NIH drawing more than 150
million in grant funding more recently
Pitt was awarded 11 million dollar grant
to create a center for excellence in big
data computing and there are many many
collaborations between that effort and
many faculty members at Carnegie Mellon
University dr. Levine has appointed
nearly every current School of Medicine
department chair he is also overseen the
addition of 10 academic departments
including immunology Plastic Surgery and
computational and systems biology
prior to his appointments at appointment
at Pitt
dr. Levine served as NIH at NIH for more
than three decades having joined the
National Cancer Institute in 1967 he
spent nearly two decades as scientific
director of the National Institute of
Child Health and Human Development which
is widely recognized as a global leader
in developmental biology and he has
co-authored or co-authored more than 250
scientific articles chaired numerous
national and international scientific
meetings and has been elected to a
number of leading research societies in
fact one of the things I found extremely
impressive about art was the fact that
any time we had an opportunity to talk
about a scientific concept he knew
exactly what some of the latest
publications were he is not only active
in his own research field but equally
he's very aware of the cutting edge of
research in various branches of medicine
he received his bachelor's degree in
comparative literature from Columbia
College his MD from the Chicago Medical
School
now the rosalind Franklin University of
Medicine and science and completed a
residency in pediatrics at the
University of Minnesota Hospitals and a
fellowship in hematology and biochemical
genetics at the University of Minnesota
ladies and gentlemen it gives me great
pleasure to invite dr. Arthur s Levine
to give his keynote address today
good afternoon this is the day when you
both look backward completing an era and
graduating and you look forward
commencing a new one my job is to both
celebrate you and push you out of the
nest I have to say that the sight of you
young scholars is inspiring it reminds
me that I is a much younger man somehow
found my own way from an undergraduate
degree in Russian literature to medical
school to developing love for research
and eventually as a slightly older man
holding a position as scientific
director of one of the National
Institutes of Health 18 years ago I
moved to a great job in Pittsburgh a
place that I knew little about having
assumed that the streets were awash in
kielbasa and sauerkraut as I reflect on
these transitions I think of four things
that I wish I'd understood at your age
as I stood in my own cap and gown first
I'm going to encourage you to think hard
about how you choose your future mentors
make no mistake you'll find mentors no
matter where you go whether it's in
business academia the arts government or
a nonprofit I've noticed an interesting
phenomenon in our medical school when a
very few which demands that the students
undertake research for all four years
while learning to be positions each is
assigned a mentor and a large number of
these medical students request placement
in the labs of our most senior most
well-known scientists they want to be
mentored by an investigator who's been
at the top of his or her field for 25
years and has been profiled in science
or nature what they don't realize is
that these people out of necessity spend
50 percent of their time traveling to
conferences and prestigious lecture
ships and another 50 percent doing the
critical work of steering whatever large
research Enterprise they lead that
leaves if you're doing the math with me
only 20% of the
time for their own hands-on research
well your CMU graduates so I know that
you've calculated what I just did
all of these renowned researchers are
occupied 120 percent of their time at a
minimum just ask their families leaving
very little if any time for mentoring
what I'd wish I'd known is that your
most important mentors are likely to be
your peers the junior colleagues who are
right there in the lab the studio on the
stage or in the workshop with you every
day people with whom you work
cheek-by-jowl recognize this and cherish
those relationships
be wary of celebrity second you should
figure out where you are most
comfortable and then get out of that
place to explore to adventure and to
take risks you may be very sure of what
you're good at and that's a great thing
but make sure you explore different
cultures and Tara gate ideas that are
antithetical to what you believe and
examine art forms that you just don't
get in short try things that don't
reflect your long-standing view of
yourself I'm actually doing that today
by giving this talk I'd be much more
comfortable with an elegant set of
powerpoints from my own lab and genomic
fidelity and its relationship to human
disease but I was quite honored when
president Suresh who by the way now also
has a faculty appointment at our School
of Medicine asked me to give this
address so I said yes before fully
absorbing the significance of that
responsibility in retrospect I'm
grateful for the challenge and for the
opportunity to challenge you I lay down
this challenge because I know now that
the most exciting ideas and advances
often occur in the space where
disciplines collide you need to find
your way to this space one critical
nexus is between the humanities and the
sciences
each informs the other an important
although often ineffable ways the result
of their interaction is the creative
spark
that has given us products like the
Tesla automobile to cite just one very
new example of the marriage of Arts and
Technology as Carnegie Mellon graduates
you know this having studied at an
institution with elite programs and
computer science neuroscience theater
arts engineering music and design there
was a time even before my lifetime when
there was no distinction between the
humanities and the sciences both are
amazing human inventions the most often
cited exemplar is Leonardo da Vinci and
his by true vien man which has come to
symbolize the connection between the two
but there are others the week he became
vice president in 1797 Thomas Jefferson
presented a paper on fossils to the
American Philosophical Society and while
serving as our nation's president he
also served as president of that society
can you imagine a contemporary president
in such a dual role
thank you
for another example of how arson science
interact consider Albert Einstein who is
slow to talk as a child what he lacked
in the early use of his voice he made up
by listening
Einstein's mother was a pianist and
Einstein himself learned to play the
violin as an adult when he hit a
roadblock in his theorizing he would
play his violin until a scientific
epiphany came to him in the midst of a
mozart sonata as einstein declared
imagination is more important than
knowledge
I worry now that the creativity that
emerges at the Nexus of science and the
humanities is threatened as many US
universities cut humanities courses in
favor of technology related skills
training courses the critic Francine
prose has considered whether the
humanities are under attack precisely
because they enable students to think in
more complex ways than the
simplifications of our current political
and corporate discourse my third bit of
advice cultivate your curiosity and
question dogma have harebrained and
crazy ideas be disruptive take risks
Abdur the incremental and the safe dare
to fail
einstein said if we knew what we were
doing it wouldn't be called research to
borrow a phrase from Richard Feynman who
said the same about quantum mechanics
science is like sex sure it may give you
some practical results but that's not
why we do it
[Applause]
my point is that research driven by
curiosity rather than by an attempt to
develop a specific application has given
us our most transformational ideas in
science this is called basic versus
applied but basic is hard it's fruits
may not emerge for years and many see it
as complex abstract Remos not practical
Einstein described the general theory of
relativity in 1910 that it didn't
eventuate in the GPS until the 90s a
more recent example is the DNA editing
technology known as CRISPR cas9 which
emerged my handful of scientists
studying a defense mechanism that
uncommon bacteria use uncommonly against
viruses dr. Jennifer down at Berkeley
once described it as probably the most
obscure thing I ever worked on that was
before she and her colleagues realized
and demonstrated that it was possible to
manipulate this bacterial mechanism to
edit the human genome almost as easily
as editing film deleting genes we don't
like and substituting new ones at will
this game-changing bio technology is
rapidly being developed now by numerous
companies for applications ranging from
human health to agriculture and we have
our innate curiosity to thank since
nobody could have predicted this outcome
when CRISPR was known only as a very
peculiar defense mechanism in uncommon
bacteria for an example of questioning
Dogma in favor of getting evidence think
of Barry Marshall dr. Marshall made the
remarkable and paradigm-shifting
discovery that peptic ulcers and stomach
cancer were caused not by gastric acid
but by a bacterium Helicobacter pylori
which can be eliminated with an
antibiotic as dr. Marshall said two
gastroenterologist the concept of a germ
causing ulcers was like saying the earth
is flat his work faced
strong headwinds of denial only winning
today when after many grant rejections
Marshall prepared a pure culture of h
pylori drank --is developed fulminant
gastritis and ulcers and luckily cured
himself with antibiotics in time to
accept his Nobel Prize my fourth and
final piece of advice find your voice
and use it if people can't understand
what you do whether it's developing
novel computer programs creating a new
musical genre or working on an
interplanetary Rover your work will not
be encouraged unless you're an ostrich
you know that we now are in the age of
alternative facts with federal agencies
from the environmental protection agency
agency to the National Endowment for
Humanities being threatened with
draconian funding cuts if not death by
executive order to quote Alan Alda
who served as host of PBS's Scientific
American frontiers communication is the
process of replacing beliefs with
information at no time as your voice
mattered more you need to tell your
stories because even politicians can be
moved by passionate narratives of how
people are helped by research innovation
the arts and the humanities but keep it
simple one fact treated with profundo t
as far more compelling than many facts
treated superficially less is more you
need to clear away the jargon and make
your audience understand exactly what is
in this for them and why they should
care don't assume that this belief or
disagreement is due to a lack of
information that can be overcome by
providing the facts rather our beliefs
and ideologies affect how we interpret
and how we respond to data when forced
to choose between evidence and
maintaining one's group identity most
people choose the latter keep that very
human tendency in mind when telling your
story to those whom you hope will
believe it
those are four things I've learned since
my own graduation choose your mentors
wisely don't get comfortable feed your
curiosity and question dogma and finally
find your voice why these four bits of
advice well it's not for your personal
fulfillment don't get me wrong I want
you to be fulfilled and I think that
this advice will help you in that regard
but I give you this advice for one
simple reason we need you we need your
talents we need you to be brave enough
to live your life creatively you've been
challenged by faculty members who demand
the original provocative work you passed
every test and by doing so you've
demonstrated that you deserve to be
among the graduates of this
world-renowned institution with that
honor and privilege comes a profound
responsibility yes a responsibility to
generate knowledge and to be a force to
make the world a better place do
something make something at the moment
we need you to help you manually figure
out how to shape a future in which we
all can thrive at the recent annual
meeting of the consortium of
universities for global health Richard
Horton editor-in-chief of The Lancet
told the audience that we have one
generation to get planetary health
rights before it is too late to reverse
the damage that has been done every era
has a zeitgeist a unique spirit or aura
that captures it the zeitgeist of your
generation may well be defined by the
singular issue but I am filled with
confidence that your generation will
achieve what humanity s of us a future
where society benefits but all that you
can offer is at stake and that
optimistic spirit let me send you off
with a few lines from my favorite poem
Ithaca by the Egyptian and Greek writer
CP calf avi
when you set out on your journey to
Ithaca pray that the road is long full
of adventure full of knowledge but if
you find her poor ethica has not
deceived you why does you have become
with so much experience you must already
have understood what ethicist mean
I thank you I thank your families and
your mentors for guiding you and I wish
you the very best of luck in all that
life holds for you
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Levine for your inspiring
words our students benefit not only from
your advice but also from this stellar
example you have set throughout your
career once again please join me in
thanking dr. Levine for joining
we will now commence with the hooding of
the doctors candidates the deans will
call forward the candidates by college
and we will announce the name of the
candidates we will begin with the
College of Engineering good evening and
let me congratulate all the doctoral
candidates tonight I'm Jim Garrett Dean
of the college of engineering will now
hood the doctors candidates from the
department of biomedical engineering
please come forward
Allen Steven Campbell enzymatic bio
sensor and bio fuel cell development
using carbon nano materials and polymer
based protein engineering
[Applause]
Catelynn Teresa Demarest prolonging the
useful lifetime of artificial lungs
[Applause]
Rebecca Marie Duffy engineering 2d and
3d skeletal and cardiac muscle for
applications in regenerative medicine
tissue engineering and soft robotics
Thomas J Hinton rapid prototyping tissue
models of mammary duct epithelium
Andrea blue Martin development and
modeling of multi scale continuous high
gradient magnetic separator for malaria
infected red blood cells
[Applause]
we will now hood the candidates from
chemical engineering Nick Austin tools
for computer aided molecular and mixture
design
[Applause]
Jacob Russell Bo's multiscale modeling
of adsorbate interactions on transition
metal alloys surfaces
[Applause]
Nicholas Glen Chisholm locomotion and
drift in viscous flows numerical and
asymptotic predictions
Wayne Wong modeling organic aerosol
formation from alpha-pinene ozonolysis
in the volatility basis set framework
Lenny karne Z volatility and chemical
aging of atmospheric organic aerosol
[Applause]
stephanie marie kirby control generation
and characterization of multi component
fluid fluid interfaces
[Applause]
Christopher Michael Knapp engineering
lipid nanoparticles for the treatment of
non-hodgkin lymphoma
[Applause]
- veronik bounce tightening techniques
for global optimization of mi NLP s
Robert Stout electrochemical dynamics
and electro kinetic particle motion in
concentrated electrolytes
Antonio's Tasso blue formation and
chemical aging of atmospheric
carbonaceous aerosol
Ming Chow you model reduction and
nonlinear model predictive control of
large-scale distributed parameter
systems with applications in solid
sorbents co2 capture
[Applause]
we will now put the candidates from the
Department of Civil and environmental
engineering
Vaibhav Agri vol multiscale phase field
model for phase transformation and
fracture Xiao Zhu Chen uncertainty
estimation in matrix based lifecycle
assessment models
prashant ja coarse graining of electric
field interactions with materials
[Applause]
George H Letterman data driven
approaches for track monitoring using
in-service trains
Karl Malden's optimal Sansom set optimal
sensor placement for infrastructure
system monitoring using probabilistic
graphical models and value of
information
[Applause]
argA nama-hatta
modeling and statistical assessment of
fluid migration response in the above
zone monitoring interval of a geologic
carbon storage site
nor Orrock statistical methods for
evaluating exposure health relationships
[Applause]
John Steg Meyer effects of
transformations of silver and cupric
oxide nanoparticles on their fate and
freshwater wetland sediments and plants
we will now hood the doctors candidates
from the Department of Electrical and
Computer Engineering Racha to us of a
room near on techniques for shared
resource management in systems with
throughput processors
[Applause]
Jing Xiu by high power high energy at
erbium doped fiber amplifier system
[Applause]
stefanos virus distributed control for
wind farm power output stabilization and
regulation
Matthew l.b Clure on chip diagnosis of
generalized delay failures using compact
fault dictionaries
[Applause]
Thiago Carvalho integrated approach to
dynamic and distributed cloud datacenter
management
[Applause]
william chan and to end
speech recognition models
Kevin KY way Chung understanding and
improving latency of deer am based
memory systems
Shihong chen data science with graphs a
signal processing perspective
[Applause]
Hong Kong Kui exploiting application
characteristics for efficient system
support of data parallel machine
learning shoe bro das distributed linear
filtering and prediction of time varying
random fields
tianyu gube improved trajectory planning
for on-road self-driving vehicles via
combined graph search optimization and
topology analysis
[Music]
min-hee Jun reconfigurable
radiofrequency front end and it's fast
optimization for adapting to dynamic
communication environments
[Applause]
chousen kim towards predictable
real-time performance on multi-core
platforms
[Applause]
hi lis storage physics and noise
mechanism in heat assisted magnetic
recording Yong Yong nice malleus
probabilistic cost enforcement of
security policies in distributed systems
Javad Mohammadi distributed
computational methods for energy
management in smart grids
[Applause]
Chaitanya Puglia a prediction and
decision framework for energy management
in smart buildings
[Applause]
nippon popli multi-layered energy
conversion and frequency control in
complex electric power systems
[Applause]
Brian W Swenson myopic best response
learning in large-scale games
[Applause]
Aleksey to mana
scheduling with space-time soft
constraints in heterogeneous cloud data
centers
[Applause]
Jun Ching way autonomous vehicle social
behavior for highway driving
[Applause]
Ching Ling Shu self-healing narrowband
MEMS filter design for RF receivers
men shoe study of the crystallization
dynamics and threshold voltage of phase
change materials for use in
reconfigurable RF switches and
non-volatile memories
[Applause]
chung-yong ultra-compact grading based
monolithic optical pulse compressor for
laser amplifier systems
Shao Qi Yin resource allocation in smart
infrastructure case studies in video
delivery and electric power networks
Xiao Zhang approaches to enable demand
response by industrial loads for
ancillary services provision
[Applause]
we will now hold the doctors candidates
from the Department of engineering and
public policy Matthew Denison Babcock
exploring and bridging group divides in
climate communications
Frankie Eriksson katate cyber security
capabilities in a critical
infrastructure sector of a developing
nation
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael J Ford studies in nuclear power
low risk and low carbon
Braque Glasgow device level data
analytics to guide policy
[Applause]
g'way Han essays on consumer switching
and search behavior
[Applause]
Nathaniel Charles Horner powering the
Information Age metrics social cost
optimization strategies and indirect
effects related to data sent related to
data center energy use
Richard Arthur huntzinger evaluating
forecasting performance in the context
of process level decisions method
platform and studies in residential
electricity demand estimation long lam
innovation in China's renewable energy
industry
Daniel Posen fuel feed stop or neither
evaluating trade-offs in the use of
biomass for greenhouse gas mitigation
[Applause]
Stephanie Seki evaluating the economic
environmental and policy impacts of
ethanol as a transportation fuel in
Pennsylvania
geoffery song making sense of the noise
statistical analysis of environmental
DNA sampling for invasive Asian carp
monitoring near the Great Lakes Chen Yin
tea market designed for the future
electricity grid modeling tools and
investment case studies
[Applause]
fan Tom the good the bad and the ugly
economic and environmental implications
of using natural gas to power on-road
vehicles in the United States
Nathaniel John Williams micro-grid
utilities for rural electrification in
East Africa challenges and opportunities
xiaochun zhang welfare properties of
recommender systems
we will now hood the doctors candidates
from the Department of material science
and engineering
[Applause]
Yvonne Batala engineering 2d cardiac
tissues using biomimetic protein micro
patterns based on the extracellular
matrix in the embryonic heart
[Music]
Brian the cost microstructure
representations applied computer vision
methods for microstructure
characterization
Vincent Guerrero de George chemical
partitioning and resultant effects on
structure and electrical properties in
code containing magnetic amorphous nano
composites for electric motors
Farzin Fotolia fard
production of titanium metal by an
electrochemical molten salt process
[Applause]
Lauren finkin our ligand mediated
stabilization of low-temperature metal
you TEDx and their use in composite
systems Phillip joins the material point
Monte Carlo model for micro structural
evolution
[Applause]
mega jump on e increased use of natural
gas in blast furnace iron-making
[Applause]
John Han Kuang electron microscopy based
characterization of resistive switches
bong Jin Lee analysis of the kinetics of
filler segregation in granular block
copolymer micro structure
[Applause]
Alexander Ali Ibrahim Mohamed sodium
titanium phosphate as an aqueous anode
degradation mechanisms and mitigation
techniques
[Music]
how you on move reduction of calcium
oxide and magnesium oxide by aluminum in
steel and inclusion modification to che
Ozturk experimental and computational
investigation of the microstructure
mechanical deformation relationship in
polycrystalline materials applied to the
additively manufactured titanium alloys
so miksa su Bedi
evaluation of micro structural and
mechanical properties of multi-layered
materials
[Applause]
Ming Tong inclusions porosity and
fatigue of aluminum silicon 10 magnesium
parts produced by selective laser
melting
[Applause]
yow-yow
growth characterization and contacts to
gallium oxide single crystal substrate
and epitaxial layers
ISA Jew effective the surface and
interface electric potential on the
photo chemical reactivity of transition
metal oxides
we will now put the doctors candidates
from the Department of Mechanical
Engineering Diego Andre de patterning
and customization evaluating tensor
field generation for mechanical design
on freeform surfaces
live Lily II Erlich thermal conductivity
of cryo protective agents with
applications to cryopreservation by
vitrification
[Applause]
Zachary Ryan Francis the effects of
laser and electron beam spot size in
additive manufacturing processes
[Applause]
cosas Kendall Goucher Lambert
investigating decision-making in
engineering design through complementary
behavioral and cognitive neural imaging
experiments Kyle
Blaine justice bio-inspired cell sense
and respond systems through bio
synthetic and robotics approaches
[Applause]
Siddarth Kamini
Babu electrode development and
characterization for polymer electrolyte
fuel cell with low to zero platinum
loading M Rula korkmaz bio dissolvable
micro needle arrays for effective
transdermal and intra dermal delivery of
vaccines and therapeutics manufacturing
and cutaneous applications
Arjun Kumar computational methods for
nanoscale x-ray computed tomography
image analysis of fuel cell and battery
materials Jung holy understanding the
visual appearance of Road scenes using a
monocular camera Tong Lu laser based
rapid prototyping techniques for liquid
metal circuits
[Applause]
trotty T Mandel investigation and
mitigation of degradation in hydrogen
fuel cells Christopher C McComb
designing the characteristics of design
teams via cognitively inspired
computational modeling
[Applause]
Oh
Sneha Prabha Nara melt pool geometry and
microstructure control across alloys in
metal based additive manufacturing
processes
[Applause]
Deepak Chandra Conte Patil particle
interactions in industrial granular
systems experiments theory and
simulations
[Applause]
Francisco V Ramirez surface plasmon
hybridization for novel plasmin
plasmonics phenomena
Charcot song soft robotic grippers using
gecko inspired fibrillar adhesives for
three-dimensional surface grasping
James Patrick Whisman selected methods
for field controlled reconfiguration of
soft matter electrical contact
congratulations to all the new doctors
candidates in the College of Engineering
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is Steve Lee I'm
the head of the School of Architecture I
am standing in today for the Dean of the
College of Fine Arts dan Martin who was
dealing with the health issue and it's
not able to be here
he sends his congratulations to all the
PhD candidates today so I will now start
the process of putting of the candidates
from the School of Architecture adrienne
chong Bayesian calibration of building
energy models for large data sets Wei Li
Xu an energy and cost performance
optimization platform for commercial
building system design
good afternoon I'm Richard shyness the
Dean of the Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences and it's
my honor to announce the candidates for
Doctor of Philosophy we'll start with
the center for the neural basis of
cognition yin-yang source space analyses
in m EG e EG and applications to explore
spatio-temporal neural dynamics in human
vision
[Applause]
pancham's Oh computational tools for
identification and analysis of neuronal
population activity will now hood
candidates from the Department of
English
Amanda Berardi tenant negotiating
concealable identities through strategic
self-reflection the rhetorics of
appalachian college student writers John
Timothy Dawson performing the public
work of rhetoric engaging difference and
supporting agency through
community-based performance and
deliberative community forums
marry Rebecca LaVon the rhetoric of
situated advocacy disability and the
price of persuasion
Jessica Blake Harrell emerging memories
a rhetorical history of remembering
after September 11th 2001
Matthew Lambert the green depression
landscape environmentalism and social
justice in the 1930s and 40s
Garret Michael stack the Sierra Club and
the rhetorical sublime
[Applause]
Jessica II Wilton bohemian enterprises
modernism cultural production and
creative labor 1913 to 1962
we will now hood the candidates from the
Department of History Ave AG I'll sue
Orem adjusting to change the Jewish
Community Center movement in post-war
urban America 1945 through 1980
Meredith Lauren Sodor jazz in a
transatlantic world legitimizing
American jazz in Germany 1922 1957
[Music]
we'll now hood the candidates from the
Department of Modern Languages maria pia
gomes liked effects of tax complex
effects of task complexity on ESL
students academic writing
we'll now hood the candidates from the
Department of Psychology brittany jakku
biak hand-in-hand combat an experimental
test of affectionate touch to promote
relational well-being and buffer stress
during couple conflict Mathew Ian Lee
heat when and where dimension based
statistical learning occurs
Emily Lindsay mindfulness training
increases positive effect defining the
critical role of acceptance in a
randomized controlled trial
we'll now hood the candidates from the
Department of Social and decision
sciences Shireen Jian Chaudhary thanking
apologizing bragging and blaming the
currency of communication
[Music]
kaitland Drummond how do you
non-scientists reason about scientific
evidence development validation and
application of the scientific reasoning
scale
[Applause]
[Music]
Talya Lazaro's beyond information the
role of emotion and hunger in
perceptions of caloric content
[Applause]
we will now hood the candidates from the
Department of Statistics Jana a sure
who's PhD advisor was Stephen Feinberg
who died tragically just a few months
ago and the last thing he did was to
sign her doctoral certificate
methodology methodological innovations
in the collection and analysis of human
rights violations data michael vespi
constructing approximately sufficient
ABC summary statistics
congratulations to the Dietrich college
doctorates
I'm remaining Dean of the a John Heinz
1/3 college of information systems and
public policy
we will now hood the cat doctors
candidates from the School of Public
Policy and management please come
forward
Guan Whaley multinational R&D offshoring
and knowledge diffusion in emerging
markets
congratulations wrong with
good evening I'm Rebecca Dortch Dean of
the Mellon College of Science and
tonight we will the doctors candidates
from The Melancholy science we'll start
with the Department of Biological
Sciences Stacey Lee Oliver the wint
signaling and actin regulator a PC to
control stem cell niche size and
architecture
Kristopher pret in vitro and in vivo
studies of BK channel trafficking and
localization using flourish and
activating peptides sahil sangani
lanthanides to probe metal induced
structural and dynamic changes in echo
our 5 DNA complex
Tanvi sasha hunt from genome to
morphology the dissection of a
developmental gene regulatory network
Daniel John cherski unlocking the door
to the surface regulated surface
trafficking of the deltoid opioid
receptor
Leena some identification of modulators
of oak glycosylation using isoform
specific sensors for gall mac trans
erase activity
Peter Millman the role of alternative
translation initiation in the regulation
of gene expression
we will now hood the candidates from the
Department of Chemistry
Hoddy ab roshan molecular modeling of
nano structures polymer electrolytes and
ionic liquids for energy environmental
and catalysis applications
Danyelle cherdon development of new
iridium photosensitizers and organic
heterocycles building from basic
electronic structures towards energy
applications serra de biochemical and
single-molecule studies of backbone
branched RNAs and lariat debranching
enzyme Minari foes bright fluorescent
nano tags for bio imaging and detection
Christian Michael Legaspi Petrus
spectroscopic and computational
investigation of emissive materials for
applications in organic light-emitting
devices
madara chuan naga babu development of
flora jhin's for the detection of
physiological analytes
Union chew diversifying catalysts
monomers cross coupling strategies and
functional groups in the controlled
synthesis of conjugated polymers
Liang Tang activating oxygen and
degrading the water treatment industry's
most challenging micro pollutant with
tamil activators and oxidants
Selma yoku next generation peptide
nucleic acids for charge and spin
transport studies
Eric J Quan spectroscopic and molecular
dynamics study of salvation and
translational dynamics in ionic liquids
Genji June precision at the nano scale
on the structure and property evolution
of gold nano clusters
we will now hood the candidates from
mathematical sciences as a first that
might be the very first
Arda Antica chiju quantifying and
improving sales diversity in recommender
systems
Ted Ishikawa
optimal investment in pricing in models
where the underlying asset may default
li you pon variational and partial
differential equation methods for image
processing
Matteo Rinaldi dynamics of phase
separation and pattern formation lively
mathematicians Sebastian veissy super
stability in abstract elementary classes
we will now hood the candidates from the
Department of Physics krysta Gabriel
Freeman viral DNA retention and ejection
controlled by capsid stability
arune kena Wandy Jayaraman systemic
effects in realistic image simulations
for future we cleansing surveys
Zach mcard geometry mechanics and
biology applications for membranes and
filaments
miele osowiec large-scale 3d mapping of
the intergalactic medium with the
lyman-alpha forest using hydro dynamic
simulations and sdss three boss dr
twelve
nikhyl sivadas first principles and
warrior functions based study of
two-dimensional electronic systems
Ananth Tonetta cosmological simulation
studies of the intrinsic alignment of
galaxies Shing wall elasticity of lipid
membrane leaflets determining pivotal
plane and tilt modules in computer
simulations
please join me in congratulating the
doctoral students from the Mellon
College of Science
hey there my name is Andrew Moore I am
the Dean of the school of computer
science we are now at the doctor's
candidates from the department of
computational biology
Theodore Roman understanding tumor
composition and evolution through
geometric models how long computational
methods for exploring gene regulation
mechanisms using high-throughput
sequencing data
we are now heard the doctors candidates
from the computer science department
john p dickerson a unified approach to
dynamic matching and barter exchange
Kristen Shoals Gartner modeling and
analyzing systems with redundancy
you only optimal approximability 'he's
beyond CSPs evangelist Papa let sakis
mining large multi aspect data
algorithms and applications
Gennady PD menker practical data
compression for modern memory
hierarchies
this ugh sha optimal social
decision-making
Duggal sutherland scalable flexible and
active learning on distributions a mayor
of alengka New Directions in coding
theory capacity and limitations
shin-soo Wang formal methods for
biological systems languages algorithms
and applications
David Karl Whitmer reputation random
constraint satisfaction problems using
the sum of squares proof system
Timothy soon meeting tail latency SLO s
in shared network storage will now hurt
candidates from the human-computer
interaction Institute Adrienne de
Freitas a framework to support
opportunistic groups in context aware
applications
Bekka
Galata digital systems and the
experience of legacy supporting
meaningful interactions with
multi-generational data
yes sir yeah near bridging physical and
virtual learning a mixed reality system
for early science
we'll now hood candidates from the
Institute for software research
Matthew bikini me detection and analysis
of online extremist communities kenneth
joseph new methods for large-scale
analyses of social identities and
stereotypes
Gabrielle Moreno adaptation timing in
self adaptive system
- sleeper everyday online sharing
w bend town do you see what I see
perception and navigation in online
deliberation Jason Chie software
developers using signals in transparent
environments
weh-weh probabilistic models of topics
and social events
will now hurt candidates from the
language technologies Institute waleed
Amma towards a universal analyzer of
natural languages
Lu Cheng web-scale multimedia search for
Internet video content
zenzen Lum toward usable multimedia
event detection
we reel in a phased ranking model for
information systems
yawn transom text as strategic choice
meow-meow when investigating virtual
teams in massive open online courses
deliberation based virtual team
formation discussion mining and support
Darry tanti we Jaya verb KB a knowledge
base of verbs for natural language
understanding z 'm analytics meta
learning
show EU surveillance video analysis with
external knowledge and internal
constraints
we'll now hooked candidates from the
machine learning department EFM are
active search for complex actions and
rewards Dusk's ah expressive
collaborative music performance via
machine learning
we will now hurt candidates from the
robotics Institute Hatem elses male
direct both estimation and refinement
jeanna thelight cross creative robotic
systems for talent based learning
christopher lynn cunningham improving
prediction of transverse ability for
planetary rovers using thermal imaging
Vishnu Rajasuya they saw a Jew safe
efficient and robust predictive control
of constrained nonlinear systems
Grayden foil efficiently sampling from
underlying physical models
David Bowie factoring scenes into 3d
structure and style
Jennifer Eileen King robust
rearrangement planning using non
prehensile interaction
heather-marie Kalinin knight expressive
motion for low degree of freedom robots
Michael C Koval robust manipulation via
contact sensing
Wow Kevin a lens Oh improving prosity
through analysis by synthesis
Michael Sherman navigation and physical
interaction with balancing robots
some moon saw the development evaluation
and application of a neuro mechanical
control model of human locomotion
Michael David Taylor calibration and
characterization of low-cost fine
particulate monitors and their effect on
individual empowerment
jeezum online lidar and vision based
eagle motion estimation and mapping
congratulations to all the new PhDs from
the school of computer science
good evening everyone my name is Bob
Damon I'm the Dean of the Tempur School
of Business I astound my pleasure to
hood the dr. candidates from The Temper
School Aaron Barclay cost and efficiency
in dynamic government outsourcing
evidence from the dredging industry
camilo Bhatia
chaparro disclosure policies bank runs
and managerial incentives Patrick PAC
Jung Choi
essays on channels and product line
design
francisco orlando sister ness veera
essays on the impact of new technologies
on firm customer relationships
oonh he Kim the mechanism of control in
organizations essays on imperfect
measures of managerial talent
amanda plummer why rub decisions about
workplace favor requests
Melanie and Zaber
three essays in household economics
congratulations to all the new doctors
and their families
this concludes our pudding ceremony for
2017 once again please join me in
extending our congratulations to all of
our doctoral candidates
to our faculty staff department heads
Dean's and senior leadership we
appreciate your dedication to these
students soon to the alum and your care
and attention to nurturing not only
their careers and scholarship but also
their well-being
once again please join me in thanking
our faculty staff and administrators
candidates please note that the degrees
will be conferred conferred at Sunday's
commencement ceremony at the stadium
that means you're not a doctor yet and
the diplomas will be presented in
especially in the special ceremonies
taking place throughout the weekend once
again congratulations I also want to
invite everyone to please join us for a
reception in the foyer that begins
momentarily after the ceremony at this
time please rise for the singing of the
alma mater led by Michael Portillo a
junior in the College of Fine Arts the
words to the alma mater can be found in
the beginning of your program thank you
here where spangled wildernesses robed
the fountains of the west where the
savage strife and stresses brought the
settlers crimson quest land of legends
glory graces gypsy tight and toiling
shore mid-thigh hilltops alma mater
stands enthroned forever more all hail
Carnegie alma mater stand and throned
for
ever
more
you